hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña kailash en el cari contreras
ella es la primera mujer trans afro e
indígena en la historia de perú en
presentarse como candidata a diputada
para las elecciones generales que están
previstas para abril de 2021 en la que
aspira por supuesto a llegar al congreso
de su país es parte del movimiento nuevo
perú y con 28 años de edad levanta la
voz de un colectivo que sufre de la
exclusión y también de la violencia en
su país cae la en primer lugar
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
imagina ya en algunas 3
para mí una química el que toma el gusto
tengo 28 y soy uno más
indígena y grande un gusto saludarte de
gael a bueno tu existencia misma está
atravesadas por llamarlo de alguna
manera no por varias formas de
disidencia no mujer trans indígena
proveniente de una familia humilde como
ha marcado todas estas características
tu vida y en particular su activismo
político
yo soy hija de campesinos he vivido he
crecido en medio del campo de la laguna
ha sufrido en carne propia las
consecuencias de la discriminación en la
desigualdad de la pobreza y eso es lo
que me ha llevado a luchar contra no
contra un sistema que contamina y que
asesina a luchar una igualdad y creo que
en a lo largo de toda mi vida
luchado por que la ciudadanía pueda
gozar plenamente de sus derechos y lo
sigo haciendo lo haré hasta donde me
alcancen la vida no la hablemos del
cuerpo como un espacio político no bien
particular para los cuerpos disidentes
como decía usted utilizaba este término
al comienzo de la entrevista la
concepción del cuerpo y de una
existencia política nos habla de cuerpos
como espacios de defensa de lo propio no
de interpretación de la realidad de
cuestionar a los patrones generales de
conducta de creación de códigos
culturales políticos que representan en
un país como perú tu cuerpo tu cuerpo
trans indígena como decía afro migrante
feminista
las personas trans las personas de mi
gente las jóvenes no solamente este país
sino del mundo entero tenemos muchas
herramientas para poder disputar pero
creo que lo que hemos explorado es
convertir su visibilidad en nuestra
principal arma para poder luchar por la
igualdad y eso ha generado que vayamos
rompiendo prejuicios y estereotipos en
el camino y en mi caso yo uso libros mis
latidos y todo mi cuerpo como
instrumento de lucha como un arma para
poder conseguir políticas públicas
normas leyes pero más allá del plano
legal va a poder lograr un cambio de
sentido común es salir y enfrentarme en
medio de todos los espacios para poder
generar cambios de fondo ha sido todo un
reto pero creo que ha valido la pena
porque vemos como cada vez hay más gente
que los echó por el mundo como cada vez
vamos rompiendo todos los serotipos y
como vamos logrando en el camino eso
hace que todo valga la pena que todo lo
que hemos hecho a lo largo de todos
estos años tenga sentido hablando de esa
lucha no y de lo que han hecho a lo
largo de todos estos años tu vida y vos
mismo lo has dicho ha sido una constante
de resistencia verdad en alguna
oportunidad incluso dijiste que sufriste
la discriminación desde el mismo
en que abriste los ojos una frase
bastante fuerte en perú hay ciertos
huecos legales en materia por ejemplo de
ley de identidad de género de matrimonio
de personas del mismo género o sexo hay
una suerte de negación crees de su
existencia por parte del estado
creo que el sistema no es nada para
nosotros para nosotros y para nosotros
no existe cuando no lo diseñaron las
personas indígenas no diseñaron las
personas trans no me enseñaron una
realizada no diseñaron hombres y géneros
heterosexuales
por eso
todas las leyes y los estados no están
pensados al servicio de toda la
ciudadanía no están en provisión
nuestros cuerpos y de nuestros afectos
sino en realidad están pensados para
poder proteger a quienes más tienen y
por eso no es casual que haya una
policía que esté al servicio y que
proteja a las mineras a los bancos pero
que la ciudadanía termine de llenándola
de bombas lacrimógenas de gas pimienta y
termina ejerciendo violencia contra
nosotras las personas trans lo sabemos
hace unos días asesinaron a dos jóvenes
dos jóvenes que lo único que buscaban
era defender su país defender sus vidas
y la pared
esto conmocionó todo el perú muchas
madres familia siguiente picaron con
estos jóvenes se dieron a reclamar y
exigir la renuncia de merino un golpista
y
[Música]
a nosotros nos lleva mucha atención a
esto porque a pesar de que yo estuve
todos los ies la calle y desde muy
tempranas a white arden las protestas
sabemos perfectamente que no es la
primera vez que sucede la policía viene
golpeando viene violentando viene usando
su fuerza desmedida de manera constante
y sistemática a lo largo de todos estos
años lo sabemos perfectamente porque las
personas trans todas las noches se nos
persigue se nos estigmatiza y se nos
trata como si no fueran seres humanos
eso hace eso de evidencia de cómo hay un
sistema está diseñado no para no para
nosotras no sino que en realidad está
diseñado para los grandes empresarios
para quienes más tienen pero que es
momento de poder romper todos estos
esquemas y empezar a construir una
sociedad basada en el amor la ternura en
el cuidado sobre todos así que no dejan
nadie fuera bueno un poco ya lo
adelantaba sgae -la pero de llegar al
congreso no varias historias no serías
la primera mujer trans
en llegar al congreso peruano
en este sentido cuáles serían tus
principales objetivos en caso de llegar
no
bueno primero que ya estamos haciendo
historia el simple hecho de disponer un
espacio e hipotecarnos a los empresarios
sin hipotecar nos a la manera haciendo
campaña desde la autogestión para jesse
con la gente esa es la historia y su ser
historia porque está grande que hay todo
un sistema que nos niega en
oportunidades que nos ponen limitaciones
en el camino hemos demostrado que hacer
política transparente sin hipotecar
nuestras agendas es posible y eso creo
yo es un logro estamos escribiendo la
historia
y creo que parte de esa historia implica
disputar por estar en ese congreso pero
no estar en este congreso para poder
hacer un voto dentro de 130 sino estar
en el congreso para empujar cambios de
fondo cambios están en fallos de la
lógica no solamente desde el aspecto
sancionador sino también desde el
aspecto preventivo que nos ayuden a
acabar con la violencia de género que
nos ayuden a acabar con la explotación
con el racismo y contra todo con todas
las formas de terminación cambios que
nos permitan en la comprensión por eso
nuestra principal propuesta de ver con
la reforma de género tiene que ver con
la lucha contra la corrupción y porque
queremos darle el mismo espacio y la
misma importancia a ambas cosas porque
lamentablemente se habla de la lucha
anti de la lucha contra la corrupción
como si fuera algo que importa demasiado
y el resto de luchas que nos interesa
ver nosotros creemos que es necesario
darle
de igual importancia a todas las agentes
por eso apostamos una ley nacional de
educación sexual integral para evitar la
crianza de futuros machistas del futuro
y ordenadores esto no es algo de
beneficio solamente bailao solamente a
mis padres o solamente las mujeres esto
beneficia a la sociedad en general que
padre no quiere que su niño que estás
viviendo sea alguien que respete y no se
convierta en un futuro violador que
madre qué padre que familia no quiere
que su niño que esté creciendo vaya a
una fiesta y regrese sana y salva y no
sea violada por 5 por 6 por 8 en una
fiesta como ha sucedido en varias partes
del país eso es lo que buscamos por dar
solamente una idea clara de cuál es una
de nuestras las obras puestas
legislativas que estamos planteando
ahora hágala también quisiera citar algo
que dijiste en una oportunidad dijiste
se han metido con la generación
equivocada tenés confianza en estas
nuevas generaciones para generar este
cambio necesario bueno un cambio en el
que vos y muchísimas compañeras y
compañeros están
esta historia como vos bien decías pero
tenés confianza en estas nuevas
generaciones para acabar definitivamente
con las violencias con las
discriminaciones que sufren en el
colectivo
estoy plenamente convencida que la calle
y la organización es el camino es
curioso como a lo largo de todos estos
años la historia la han escrito los
hombres y los políticos tradicionales
pero no está viviendo un proceso de
cambios cambios que plantean
cuestionarlo todo mirarlo de manera
diferente y eso ha hecho que sea la
calle sea la ciudadanía organizada la
que provoque la renuncia de merino
porque ojo merino ha renunciado hace
unos días tras cinco días de intentar
quedarse en la presidencia del perú
y eso no ha sido casual yo estoy segura
y nadie
lo contrario pero merino tenía planeado
dar un golpe de estado para renunciar a
los cinco días evidentemente su renuncia
ha sido provocada y ha sido provocada
por una generación de jóvenes y mujeres
de personas del gt veis alzando sus
voces en las calles juntando sus
conexiones poniendo por encima de la
mesa la necesidad de tener que empujar
cambios de cuando de tener que bajar a
toda esa clase de política tradicional
que nos hayan mostrado en la vida y que
la problemática de las personas de este
país no les interesa porque lo único que
les ha importado ha sido atornillarse en
poder quedarse en un espacio donde se
toman decisiones seguir cobrando jugosos
sueldos mientras continúan evadiendo las
investigaciones mientras siguen en la
unidad por eso creo que a pesar de el
dolor de haber perdido ahí y habrá ya
la difícil situación que atravesamos hay
un horizonte bastante motivador el ver
que cada vez hay más y más jóvenes
exigiendo una nueva constitución
reclamando y exigiendo lo que les parece
injusto demuestra que
de esa generación a la textura es amargo
está dispuesto hasta dar su vida por
este país está dispuesta a dar su vida
por la igualdad está dispuesta a
construir una sociedad con justicia
social y eso no hace más que motivarme y
llenarme de alegría en medio de todo es
un abrazo y muchas gracias hay aire
nuevamente gracias a ti adela ya nuestra
audiencia como siempre le invitamos a
continuar informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y en france24 punto
com
[Música]
y